サッブパッパスアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチットパリヨーダタナン エータン ブッダナサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
はい 一番最初に回向しなくちゃいけないことがありまして
あの 今日の会場の 費用
費用ね かなり高額ですけど
あの前田真理子さんのお布施でございます
これは単純なお布施というよりは
法施に説法 皆様に聞いていただきたいという
真理子さんがね 金額を通して皆様に真理のお布施をしています
ですから それはお布施の中で一番最高なお布施になります
まあそれ 真理子様がね
まあそれは親孝行する目的で
自分の父親がかなり厳しい状態で今いるので
父親に祝福と功徳を回向してほしいという気持ちで
そのお布施をいただき
お布施いたしました 仏法僧にそのお布施をしたことになります
ですから 確実にこの真理子さんのお父様と他の功徳を期待する方々には
ものすごい大変な功徳になると思います
この世の幸福 あの世で幸福
解脱に達するために この功徳が役に立つもの
力になるものだと思います
ですから 皆様方は一緒に前田真理子様のお父様と他の功徳を期待する
功徳を必要とするすべての皆様の先祖方やら友人たちやら
皆に幸福がありますように
心が清らかになりますように
煩悩がなくなりますように
完全たる解脱 幸福である解脱涅槃に達することができますようにと誓願いたしまして
3回サードサードサードと言いましょう
サードサードサード はい
ありがとうございます
はい では今日の講演始まります
講演やっていて疲れてしまったらね
私はこのスライドに書いてない一番難しい仏教のね
ところがありまして それは講演終わってから説明しようかなと思ってたんですけど
これはスライドにはしないことにはしたんです
今日は仏教と文化のお話なんですね
それより前に仏教とは何なのかと
お釈迦様が教えた真理は
まとめると この因果法則ということになります
この世で全ての現象が
自分が生きることであろうが
もう一切の物事は あらゆる原因と条件が揃って一時的に現れるものであると
それは因果法則の基本
それから どんな原因でどんな結果になるのかということは
釈尊が説かれたものなんです
その中でも もう太陽のことやら宇宙のことやら
もう何の関係もないんだから
お釈迦様は説かれていないんです
しかし 生命がどういうふうに生まれて現れて消えていくのかって
この過程を因果法則で説かれたんです
他は人間には把握できないことで
私は何者かっていうことだけ因果法則で理解すれば解脱に達しますから
それで十分であると はい
それで一切は因果法則であるならば
文化であろうが因果法則
文明であろうが因果法則
文明が壊れようが因果法則
人類が殲滅するになろうか
因果法則 因果法則にならないものっていうのは
何一つもないんです なんでも我々にはすべての因果法則はわからないんだけど
何か 1個一つの現象を調べると
なんでこの現象が現れたのかっていうことは
それなりに調べられます
問題なく 例えば知ってる植物のところに行って
いろいろ葉っぱがある
その その植物に同じ種類の葉っぱがある
よくよく見ると 葉っぱ一枚一枚同じじゃないんですね
それぞれ一つの枝の葉っぱであろうか
葉っぱ一枚一枚は自分のアイデンティティを持ってるんですね
よく調べてください 例えば柿の木があって
あ 柿の葉やとかね でもそんな単純にはまとめることできません
よーく見ると 柿の葉っぱであろうか
一枚一枚自分自身のアイデンティティを持っているんです
違うんですよ それでなんでこの葉っぱがすごく大きくて
なんでこの葉っぱが細くて
なんでこの葉っぱがちょっと硬くて
なんでこの葉っぱが薄くてとかね
いろいろありますね それぞれには因果法則があります
それぐらいは誰にだってそんなに難しくないと思いますね
例えば葉っぱの色にしても同じじゃないね
じゃあみんな大雑把で同じ色やと思っちゃうでしょ
だからもう世の中 まあ本当にもういい加減なものになっているんですね
そうじゃないんです じゃあ
葉っぱの色という現象に集中して
一つの植物の一つの枝の葉っぱを見てみる
そうすると やっぱり色でもばらつきがあるんだよということは見えてくる
だからなんでそうなっているのかっていうことが因果法則なんですね
なんとかそういうシンプルな項目を一つ選べば
因果法則の働きがわかるんです
それからもう一つありますね
では 柿の木の葉っぱは一枚一枚自分のアイデンティティ
アイデンティティを持っているんだと言っても
一枚一枚葉っぱがそれぞれ違うんだと
ぴったし工場で作った製品みたいに同じじゃないんだと
わかっても 柿のは柿の葉で
日本中にある柿の葉の葉もまた似ているでしょ
いたって簡単に見たら
あ これは柿の葉とわかります
でもアイデンティティあるんです
これって何ですかね？それは因果法則なんです
因果法則の中でいろいろ現象っていうのは
一つのパターンというものを持っているんです
例えば柿の木の場合は
葉っぱを作る時のパターンがあります
なんとか原型みたいに
そのパターンに合わせて葉っぱを作って作っていくんですね
しかし 出来上がった葉っぱは一枚一枚違う
独立性がある だから独立であるながら
ありながら共通性があり
でしょ？難しい？簡単でしょうね
柿の木の葉っぱ 1枚1枚
それぞれ別々独立している
自分のアイデンティティを持っている
しかし また何かみんな同じ共通ってことはある
もし難しくてわからないんだったら
皆様はみんな日本民族でしょ？日本人でしょ
だから同じでしょ 結局は
だから外国人にとっては
例えばアジア人に 特にね
日本人同じに見えるんですよ
私はそう見えませんと
日本にいるんだからね
みんな同じ型で作った人間に見えちゃうんです
皆様も知ってるで 皆様は人を見たら日本人ならばしっかり
ということは 日本人であるというためには
何か共通形があるんです
しかし 一人一人違うでしょ
一人一人が違う その 2つ理解してください
日本人として同じ型で出来上がってますけど
一人一人が自分の違うところ
アイデンティティの形も持っている
はい 因果法則を理解する場合は
そういう風に2つを理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
本当に瞑想するならばね
そんな難しくないんだけど
瞑想しないでしょうね
だから難しい話を聞く羽目になるんです
私のせいじゃないんです
それで今日はこの因果法則のこのパターンということ
ちょっと理解しましょう
要するに 共通性 独立性じゃないんです
英語で言えばコモンプロパティというもので
ディフェレンシャルプロパティではないんですね
だから共通性 えーと これはどこでもみんなよく言うでしょ
ワンパターン ワンパターンとかね
そんなものに我々は生きている上で
いろんなパターンを学ぶんです
それからパターンを繰り返すんです
なぜ子どもたちが生まれてきて
ちっちゃな子どもたちが何も知らない
それで親がありがとうと言ってくださいとか
はい ありがとうは？とかね
そういう何か教えるんですね
何か失敗したら じゃあごめんなさいは？と言うんですね
それで子どもは嫌嫌でごめんなちゃいと言うんですね
それでちょっと時間経つと
子どもは何のことなくありがとう
ごめんなさいと言えるようになっているんです
このパターンを学んだんです
最初はお辞儀の仕方もわからない
それで教えてあげると
そのパターンを学ぶんです
例えば 日本の食文化では
みそ汁というのはかなりの大きなアイテムなんですね
必ずみそ汁がある これは沖縄から北海道どこでもみそはみそでしょ
一つのパターンなんです
作り方は決まってる 出汁入れる
水を入れるとなんとか具を入れて温めて
ちょっと温めたら下ろすというね
それだけパターンは しかし
どんな家のみそ汁 完璧
ぴったし同じ味というわけじゃないんですね
怠けて店で売ってるインスタントパックを買ってお湯をかけると
まあ知らん それはかわいそうな人間でね
あまりにもパターンだけにはまっちゃって
怠けでだいたいパターンにはまるところはちょこっと怠けが入ってるんですね
しかし 元気な人でも自分で味噌汁作るんだけど
あのパターンは壊す 壊せないんですね
水を入れて出汁を入れて
出汁の場合はいろいろありますね
もうカツオ出汁使うか
煮干し入れるか 昆布を入れるか
あるいは顆粒の出汁を入れるかとか
そこら辺でいろいろ違いますけどね
それでパターンがあって
このパターンでやっちゃうんですね
そういうことは 我々にとっては何かパターンにハマっちゃって
マンネリになった方が生活しやすいんですね
これ 世の中によくあります
決まりとかね これはもう昔からの決まりやとかね
そうやってパターンあるんですよ
パターンを繰り返し繰り返しリピートして
ループでリピートするんです
この無常を理解できない一つの理由もそれなんですね
因果法則がわからないこと
パターンは因果法則なんです
我々は赤ちゃんで生まれて
もう今もうみんなに嫌がられる年寄りになってるでしょうに
でもずっと自分だと思っちゃうんですね
自分の細胞死んで死んで新しい細胞が生まれてるんだけど
違うんだけど どこかで同じパターン繰り返すっていうことがあるんですね
だからよくわからないと
子供を見て 1週間経ってから同じ子供を見ても変わってるとわからないんですね
1週間で変わってますよ
なぜかというと 変わったのは変わったんだけど
同じパターンで繰り返しちゃったんです
だから ある家で 1週間味噌汁作ったことと同じですよ
初日の日に作った味噌汁もう食べちゃったでしょ
もうない また新しい水を入れて
同じ鍋かもしれませんだけど
また別な材料を入れて
2日目別な味噌作るんですね
3日目  4日目 もう 7日目まで別々な味噌汁なんですけど
でも我々は同じやと思っちゃうでしょ
だってパターン同じだから
出汁の量やら水の量やら味噌の量やらね
その家では決まってるんです
だから同じ家で 1週間味噌汁食べてみても
同じ味やと変わっちゃうんです
しかし 違うんですけどね
全く違うのに そういうことで
我々にはパターン作った方が生きやすい
失敗は減る 特に料理作る場合は
みんな何かあれ 本を見ながら作ってるでしょ？ 1 1 これこれやって
2 これこれやって 量はこれはこれぐらい
これはこれぐらい これをぴったしそれに合わせちゃうと
料理できない人でもそう
それなりに出来上がっちゃうんですよ
ちゃんと料理本に言ってる通りにやったならば
火の強さまでね で 火にかけてる時間までちゃんとテキスト通りにやっちゃうと
下手な人にもできますね
最初にやって試す料理でも
なんかうまく出来上がっちゃうんですね
ということで パターンにハマった方が
マンネリになった方が
我々には失敗少なく 危険少なくして
それからあまり緊張しちゃって怯えちゃって
することもギリギリ減らして
いくらか楽々に生きられる
だから因果法則っていうのは
宇宙的な巨大な因果法則がありながら
我々は個別性で見ると
私たちはパターンを作っているんです
例えば 私も生命で犬も生命なんですけど
因果法則 私にも犬にも同じなんです
しかし こっちは人間だから
人間のパターンがあるんです
このパターンにハマって回転するんです
犬は肉体 犬だから犬のパターンがあるんです
生命だから私もご飯食べる
犬もご飯食べてます しかし
私はサラダ食べているんだけどね
トマトも食べるんだけど
犬は食べない カリカリ食べてます
あるいはチーズとか肉とかあげちゃったらパクッと食べますけど
同時にジャガイモあげてください
それは食べませんね はい
そこでこれ 犬の肉体のパターン
こちらは人間の肉体のパターン
カラスのカラスの肉体のパターン
このパターンにハマっていた方が余計なことをしないでね
大胆なことをしないで
パターンにハマって ロボットのように動けば相当楽です
失敗は少ないです これ
ロボットのようにと言っちゃうと
なんか批判されたようなことに見えますけど
聞こえますけど これ因果法則ですよ
しょうがないんです はい
そこでこの地球で生き物が現れて
生き物がいろんな分類になっちゃって
その中で猿というグループが現れて
その中でまたパターンができちゃって
猿の種類が現れちゃって
それからさらにパターンができちゃって
猿もいろいろ変わったりして
あっ 立って走る猿たちも出てきて
それからまたパターンが現れちゃって
立って走る 歩ける猿は両手が自由だからね
こいつら両手をくだらんことに使い始めちゃって
どんどんパターンがパターン
いろんな小さいパターンが新たに現れて
人間も現れたんです で
まだ野生です それからまたいくいろいろパターンが現れて現れて
火を見つかったり 料理の方法を見つけたり
それでまた料理の方 例えば昔
一番最初 もしかするとただ焼いて食べただけかもね
私は当時いなかったんだから
はっきり言えません 何も
で 焼いて食べたかもね
それから食べ物の焼き方のパターンが現れる
それで親が教える 炎で焼くか
炭で焼くかとかね それ風ないろいろパターンが現れて
やがて何か現れるんですか？これが現れるんです
シヴィライゼーション
おそらく日本の単語は文明やと思いますね
それはまあ 一応英語の単語で考えてますから
シヴィライゼーション
シヴィルっていうのは
いくらかまあ文明的な人間というね
シヴィライズドパーソン
野生じゃないって意味なんです
ノットワイルド ワイルドじゃん
あ 日本語のワイルドは別な意味なんですね
そうじゃなくて 普通英語のワイルド
ワイルド いわゆる野生
なんで野生っていう単語ありますけど
なかなかパターンにはめられませんね
難しい だから野生動物と飼ってる動物違うでしょ？ただ
牛なんかは野生で見るでしょ？私たち飼ってる牛見るでしょ？違うんですね
飼ってる牛は人間 決まったパターンにはまっている
野生の牛はそんなパターンきかない
だからパターンがそれほどない場合は野生でパターンが出来上がっちゃうと
野生の反対は civil なんですね
動物の場合はテイムと言いますけど
普通人間でも civil という言葉を使っているんですね
だからシヴィライゼーション
文明が現れるんです  それから簡単ですね
時間的に長く続く より広く人間の間で行う生き方
習慣などですよ シヴィライゼーションというのは
だから文明というのはかなり長く持ちます
皆様の服の色とかね 服のデザインみたいに一年四回変わることはないんです
相当長いんです 長く続くんです
でも大したことない どんなパターンでしょうかと
生きる場合は だから生き方
習慣 そんなもんですよ
文明っていうのは 昔はいくつかの文明がありましたが
今は文明一つですね かなり昔ね
これは  1000万単位でしょうね
おそらく 万ではないね
中国には文化がありまして
まあいろいろ壊れたんだけど
中国文化はそれほど問題なくありますね
他の文化は壊れたでしょ？文化ではなくて
文明は すごい優れた文明あったんでしょ？インドにも
パキスタン辺りとかね
このインダス文明と これがモヘンジョダロ文明とか
すごい優れたものあったんですね
エジプトにあったり いろいろ古代文明と言うんですからね
なくなっちゃったんですね
跡形もなく それで新しい文明が現れる
それで今我々はほとんど一つの文明なんですね
中国人の古い文明はそのままなくならなかったんだけど
今中国人も結局は現代文明で生きているんですね
しかし 民族 国 地方に限ったマイナー文明もありますね
だから日本の方々は一生懸命アメリカ文明文化をね
こんなまま猿真似しようと頑張ってるでしょ
いくら なってもアメリカ人にならないね
やっぱり自分たちの日本人としてのあれが何か残っちゃうんですね
そういうわけで 沖縄の沖縄の文明があって
もうそれぞれ 個人に個人の文明もあることも理解する
これがポイントなんです
だから この地方になってくると
学問的な文明と言わないんですよ
文化と言うんですね 沖縄文化
秋田県の文化とかね そういう風に言うんだけど
文化は後で説明します
文明 この文明っていうのはものすごく自然なんです
自然に表れてくるんです
無理やり押し付ける必要はないんです
だから文明はかなり長持ちします
文化より長持ちします
しかし 個人の文明ありますよ
例えば今は今の文明というのはほとんどデジタルで電子文明に成り代わっているでしょ
何でも電子信号に依存しようと
昔はお金を持っていたのに
今は数字しか持ってない
数字といったっても いくつかの電気信号だけなんです
昔は人と喋ったのに 今は信号で喋って
あるいは携帯で喋って
あるいは携帯でメールを送ったりする
メッセージを送ったりする
だから英語の単語 日本語はよくわかりますよ
テキストとかね メッセージとかね
今までなかった言葉まで現れてるんです
例えば GOOGLEっていうのは会社の名前でしょ
あれ 今動詞になってますね
あ これ日本語で言えば何でしたっけね Just
Google it. 英語で言えばね
ググるです  ググる そういう風に変な単語まで現れるんです
しかし それ誰も無理やり教えた？強引にこれ勉強しろよと
ないんですね 素直に受けているんです
それが文明なんです そこではい
今 電子文明 完璧 電子文明ではないんだけど
まあ一応電子文明に変わっていく
しかし 私はどのように携帯使うのか
私のパソコン 私はどのように使っているのかと私勝手です
今日私の携帯を見たら
何かあのミスミスコールと英語で言いますけどね
これも新しい言葉でね
あって その瞬間に思い立ったのは
私には 1ヶ月間一回も電話かけてこない
だから携帯はどこかに置いたままで忘れちゃう
どこにあるかと そこで 1ヶ月に一回ぐらい電話かけてきたっても
これミスコールになっちゃう
だって頭にないんで 電話誰かかけたらさっさと取って返事しなくちゃいけないっていう
ですから 私の携帯の使い方って
皆様の携帯の使い方と違うでしょ
皆様方からは携帯ちょっと 30 分取り離しちゃうと心臓発作で死ぬんです
階段を上りながらやっている
エスカレーターで一生懸命これやっている
昨日 窓から外のでっかい大きなアパートありましたからね
そこら見てると なんかまあ土曜日だからね
子供たちとかね まあ学校で早く戻ってるんですね
いてるの 若い子を見ていたんだけど
この建物に入る前にも階段どうであろう
なんのこと 真剣 これなんですね
それでずっと大きいでっかいビルですけどね
ずっと歩きながら どうやって自分の家に行けるかよくわかりませんだけど
これから目が離せないんですね
取っちゃったら もしかすると呼吸を止めたような感じになるでしょうね
だからそこで個人文化でしょ
あの子は無理やり学校の先生に強引にそういう風に使ってくださいと言った？言ってない
やめろと言っているはずなんです
だからそこは喜んでやっているし
依存度はそれぞれバラバラだから
個人個人の文明もあります
覚えておいてください
はい 個人の文明についてね
文明とは人類が一般的に疑問を持たず行う生き方です
ちょっとかっこいい日本語ではそんなもんなんです
しかし 食べ方 服の着方
言語の使い方 家の設計
内装などなど個人好みがあるんです
日本人が家を作る場合は
日本で日本の文明に 日本の建築文明に合わせるんです
全体的にどこでも しかし
自分の家は隣家とは違います
文明として生きることに失敗しても
犯罪 犯罪者になる個人もいるのです
失敗して そこで文明に失敗すると犯罪者なんです
文明に失敗するはずがない
文明っていうのはなんか素直に受けるものなんです
文明から逃げられません
でも失敗する人いるんですよ
そういった人は明らかに犯罪者になるんです
例えば 日本で起こる犯罪リストを見てください
文明人じゃないでしょ
わかる わかりやすく言えば
家に入って家にいた二人も殺しちゃってお金を持って行ったとか
文明人 例えば電車に乗って痴漢したならば文明人
だから犯罪は定義いたって簡単
文明を壊しちゃったんです
世界の流れ 生き方 流れ
生き方がある 自分は一部を選んで生活する
文明から自分が選ぶ分は個人の文明です
だから世界全体的に流れがあります
世界全体的に見ると生き方があります
それから私たちは自分に必要な量だけ取ってパターンを作るんです
じゃあバカでかい 何でしたっけ
ブッフェだと思ってください
あんまりにもマンモスブッフェがある
全部歩こうと思っても 30 分
1時間ぐらいかかるぐらい
そこで食べ物もそういうことでしょう
いろんなものがあったりして
それで自分があれ全部食べる
ね 自分が自分の皿を持って
自分好きなものを自分のお腹に入る量だけ取って
どこかに行って座ってそれを食べる
しかし ブッフェは巨大
文明というのはそういうふうに巨大なブッフェのようなもので
個人個人がその中から一部取って
自分 それを使って生きているんです
それには個人文明と言うんです The
civilization and personalized civilization
はい 文明の運命 文明は常に変わっていくんです
それは気をつけてほしいんです
文明はすごい巨大神のような存在ですけど
変わるんです 悪い習慣が現れた
現れたり 戦争を引き起こしたり
良い習慣が消えたりするので
一概に文明は発達するのだとは決められない
例えば みんなもう一般人が西洋的な現代的な知識で発展するんだ
発展するんだ アホなことを言ってるんですよ
50年前より我々は発展しているんだとかね
この偏見というのは現代知識の特色なんですね
偏見と間違うということは
私 仏教的には発展という言葉を使いません
変化する 流れる 例えば文明を見ると良い習慣があったのに
今は跡形もなく消えている
それから文明は人間が平和で楽ちんでらくらく安らかに生きるために作るものなんです
文明というのは しかし
戦争を引き起こしたのは誰？それは文明なんです
ですから 戦争の場合は戦争文化と言うんだけど
まあ結局は文明を生み出すんですね
それで悪い習慣が現れる場合
良い習慣が消える それもありますから
発展ではなく変化だと言いましょう
例えば 昔より良い習慣も現れる
例えば 文明的に女性を差別する習慣があったんですね
だから 各国ではなくて
世界的にも それはおかしいと平等という風になってくると
いい文明にいい習慣 いいパターンが入ったんです
習慣というよりはニューパターン
入ったんです はい 古代文明が跡形もなく消えたから
今の文明も必ずその道を歩むんです
今の文明もね 跡形もなく消えるんです
生まれた人間は文明人になるように学ぶんです
そこで生まれた赤ちゃんが文明人じゃないんです
猿です だから人間に怒られますけど
時々ちっちゃな子供たちはこちょこちょと歩くと
私には本当に猿で見えるんですよ
それから 自分で何もできない子供がどんどん文明人になっていくんです
はい 次 文化に行きます
それでシヴィライゼーション
これから英語の単語を使ってないんだけど
あのシヴィライゼーション
文化は英語で何でしたっけ？カルチャー
カルチャーっていうのは意図的に作る
という意味なんです だから文明は
我々は何の疑問も持たず
文明の中に生きているんです
カルチャーはそうじゃないんです
文化は 文字通りに人々は意図的に作るしきたり
習慣 信仰 お祭り 服装 価値観などは文化なんです
かなり強引なんです でもそれもパターンなんですよ
いろいろパターン作っては入れる
パターン作っては入れる
はい 文明人が文化を作りますから
文明の中に無数の文化が現れるんです
だから文明も人間作りますよ
しかし それはすごく自然
長持ちもする その人間が小さな小さな個別のパターンを無理やり作るんです
無理やり それが文化というんです
もう一つ 文明は自然法則に合っています
文化はそんなことあまり気にしない
自然法則に合っているかないかと
あのカルチャーという単語があるでしょ
それで URE 消しちゃうと何が残る？カルチャーの文字います CULTURE URE
抜けちゃうと CULT だけでしょう
どう読む？カルト カルト
カルトは自然法則に従ったもの
すごい変なものでしょ
だから世の中にあるカルトも一つの文化なんです
それから そちら数字ちょっと変わりますけど O
を入れたらなります 何になりますか？その場合 OCC
なんですけど 何？オカルト
文化です オカルト 文化はそれぞれ作ったグループが守ります
文化は人類は守りませんよ
文化を作ったアホのグループがそれを守っているんです
だからカルトを作ったグループは
そのカルトを大事に守る
オカルトを作ったグループは
そのオカルトを大事に守る
世界的にいろんなオカルトがありますね
でもみんなオカルトだから
私はオカルトをやってるんだから
世界中のオカルトを学ぶ
それはないんです 自分のオカルトだけやってるんです
だから宗教は何ですか？文明
文化 文化です なんで勝手に作ったんだから
ですから 宗教は人類を守らなくちゃという義務はない
自分勝手に作った宗教は
自分勝手に信仰すればいいんです
他の人には関係ないんです
別なグループは別な文化を作ります
文化も常に変わっていくものです
これは文化人の無知な連中
それなんで知らないのかと
文化を作る時点でアホなんですけど
まあアホというのは因果法則です
批判と言いますけど やっぱりパターンを作らなくちゃ生きていられないんですよ
例えば日本は現代文明の人々
日本人は しかし 日本国では日本文化なんですね
日本文明というものはないんです
日本文化 中国人は現代文明の人々です
しかし 中国は中国文化なんです
2つですね やっぱり文化がないとね
なんか面倒くさいんですね
だから日本人には日本という文化があるんだから
結構楽ちんで生きているんです
しかし 文化も変わるんです
はい 文化の強弱 歴史が長いこと
守る人々の数が多いこと
他人が賛成することなどは文化の強さです
だから中国文化は強いんです
なんで？歴史長い それでインド
インドの文化 インディアンカルチャー
歴史が長いんですよ だから強いんです
なかなか簡単には変わりません
もう一つは人数 一番人数の多いのは中国文化なんですね
かなわないんです だから日本人が勝手に中国を潰してやると思ってるでしょ？諦めてください
これは無理 それよりは素直に中国文化を学んだ方が楽です
昔 日本人の頭良かったんだからね
中国に行って 行っては学んで帰る
行っては学んで帰る 日本の皇室も新しい天皇が現れちゃうと
中国の何かの言葉で平成やらなんだらかんだらやら自分の名前まで変える
その方が平和で楽ちんです
中国に思い知らせてやろうと思って
何か年号を作っちゃうとまずいことになります
別に戦争になるわけじゃなくてね
文化はそれすごいもんでしょ
だから私はスリランカ人だからスリランカ文化なんですね
しかし 隣は誰ですか？インドなんです
だからインド文化にはちょっかいは出しません
それは大変なことになるんです
それで賛成する人々の数
例えば なんで私たちは何のことなくアメリカ文化
ヨーロッパ文化をすごく大事にするんですかね
大したこと歴史もないし
見ても単純な生き方でしょ
料理にしたっても 本当にシンプルな料理のやり方で全然面白くない
何でもシンプルで決まっちゃって
で アメリカいくらかアメリカというのは移民でできた国だから
アメリカ英語はすごく面白くはなってるんです
決まりパターンじゃない
しかし 英語の本場はイギリスでしょ
すんごいらないんですよ
あの英語は全部フレーズ暗記して
そのように使うしかないんです
自分で新しいフレーズ作れません
例えば イギリス人に I'm going to kill you.と言ったら
あ 本気で私はあなたを殺しますよという意味になっちゃうんです
アメリカ英語で I'm going to kill you.と言ったら
もうそんなそんな意味じゃない
からかってるだけなんです
お前と思う お前 ひどい目にあわせてやるぞと
例えばゲームの場合で I'm going to kill you.と言えます
ということは 人を殺しているないんです
あなたに勝ちますよという意味なんですね
だから 相手がイギリス人だったら
そういうことをやめた方がいいんです
で アメリカ人が何かちょっといいことって
ああ ディスマーベラスって言っちゃうでしょ
英語ではそれはよくいかない
マーベラスというのはものすごく違う意味なんです
信じられないぐらいびっくりする
飛び上がるほどことにはマーベラスって言うんです
アメリカに行ったら お箸をしっかり並べて置いただけでお
マーベラスって言うんです
そういうことで あの いろいろ文化の差がありますけどね
しかし 私たちも もう喋ってる私もアメリカ英語の真似したり
イギリス英語も もともとイギリス英語を勉強しちゃったんだけど
なんでそれやるんですかね？これ
賛成する人々の数が多いんです
だってインドでも教育は英語でしょ
仕方がないんです だから私たちは何人であろうとも外国語を学ぼうではないかと思ったとて
第一に来るのは英語です
何か外国語を学んで 外国国際的な関係を持たなくちゃいけない
ですから 私はスワヒリ語を学びますと誰か思う？思わないね
それは文化の強さなんですね
影響力の強い文化の影響を受けること
文化人の興味がなくなること
新しい世代が新たな文化を作ることなどが文化の弱みです
だから今 日本文化っていうのは弱いんです
なぜ 西洋の文化があんまりもきつく入って入って
がんみたいに広がっているんだから
だから大人でもクリスマスやるんだから
もう話にならないんです
大人に子供たちいたら
こいつらもハロウィンやっちゃうんです
恥ずかしくてしょうがないんだけど
どうなってますか これは
西洋文化の方が強いんだから
ギイって小さな文化をいじりしめて入り込むんです
それは文化の弱みというんです
それから文化人の興味がなくなる
例えば日本のね 例えば１００年前の文化があったんだけど
今は興味ない そうするとそれは消えてしまいます
忘れてしまいます だから文化が生き延びるためには
ずっと人の興味が必要ですよ
大事だ 大事だとか もう一つ
文化にこれは必ずあります
文化っていうのは人間作るものでしょ
本当に文化作るのは若者なんです
親が古い文化を子供に押し押し付けようと思うんですね
でも子供がそう簡単に鵜呑みに鵜呑みにしないんです
何かなにかそれ変えて自分の文化を作るんです
ですから 大雑把に計算すると
文化っていうのは１０年ごとに結構派手な変わりがあるんです １
年ごとにも変わりますけど
あまり気づかない  文化がただの習慣になって
正しい客観的に立証できないことも弱みです
文化というのはただの習慣ですよ
立証できない 例えばオカルト
ただ頭イカれてるんだからやっているだけで
これ科学的に正しいと立証できんでしょ
例えば日本人が葬式に行ったら
お塩をちょっとかけて清めるでしょ
あれで清める ただの文化でしょ
だから誰かがこんなことをアホくさい
やめますと思ったらしょうがないんですね
それもそれがすごい弱みですね
文化の アホくさくてやっていられないと思われたら終わりです
それから個人文化 個人にも個人の生き方がありますね
当たり前 自分が生きる社会の文化をそのまま守ることはしません
皆様 日本社会の文化は全然そのまま守っていない
自分自分にのバージョンがあります
自分で守るしきたり 習慣
儀式 儀礼を自分で選ぶんです
これ私もよく見るんで
私は起き上げたり いろいろ瞑想会の場合はね
はい ではみんな合掌してください
これから起き上げますから
合掌する人もいて いくら言っても合掌しない人もいるんです
それでわざと私は二 三回言うんですね
まあ起き上げてるなら合掌してくださいと
ちょっと目も見るんです
やらないよ それでも合掌しない人はしない
ですから まあ私は別に文化のどういうことを知っているんだから
厳しく 君 なんでその姿は失礼でしょうと言わない
それはその個人の文化なんです
みんな合掌しているのに
合掌しない人が現れる
社会の批判を怯えて嫌々で守る習慣もあるんです
それから やりたくないんだけど
やる文化もありますね
社会が怖い はい 今日の大事なポイントはこれから現れますね
宗教 信仰と文化 あの宗教は文明を作りません
宗教そのものは文化だからね
そんな力がないんです
文化の大半は宗教を作ります
宗教が作ります 世にある文化はすべて調べてみると
裏宗教が絡んでいるんです
ヤクザみたい だって 日本のどんな社会見ても裏ヤクザが隠れているでしょ
特に政治世界はね そこは大反対や法律まで作って暴力を追放しましょうと
でも暴力団と仲良くやってます
もしかすると暴力団を追放する法律をする時でも
暴力団のボスがアドバイスする可能性はいくらでもあります
はい 赤鬼と青鬼 日本の迷信信仰は赤鬼
青鬼の文化を作ったので
これは単なる例で 皆様すごい頭がいいんだから
これはどんどんどんどん宿題で伸ばしてみてください
この 1 行で終わりたいんです
要するに 日本では赤鬼
青鬼という文化があります
どこか地方でも行ったら
ずっとでっかい鬼の装束って並べているんですね
それでもみんな見学に行ったり
観光客を呼ばせ呼ばよんだりしてね
でも赤鬼 しかし 誰一人も鬼を鬼に会ったことがないでしょう
会った人はいる？いた？今亡くなってもいいんですけど
赤鬼 青鬼の物語を作った人々は勝手に作ったストーリーでしょ
これが文化になっちゃって
今の連中は人々はマジいると思ってるんです
だから鬼はせと福は内になっているんです
それやるたびに汚い考えだから不幸にはなります
仏教心理学では やるたびにあなたは不幸になりますよと
でもやりますよ 東京の成田さんだったら派手でしょ
この豆まきの文化が でおばちゃんたちが全部拾ってね
大事 なんか見てください
こういうこういうところでああいういろんなもの
あの食べ物やらいろんなもの
あの豆落ちたら食べられません
今はちゃんと袋に入れて
ちゃんと投げるんですよ
あれ 拾う姿を見てください
なんかあの植えている国に何か援助物質を落としたような感じでしょ
この立派な日本人が 恥ずかしく思わないでしょ
文化だからなんです だから
私みたいな頭光れて人から見たら
この連中は 1ヶ月間も食い物なかったみたいやという風に言える
悪口言えることは言えるんです
でもあれは食い物なくないんだから
これ取って食ってやろうではないんです
自分にとっては大事な文化なんです
だから喧嘩して取るんです
その中に豆とか それからあの
米が硬くしたあれ 何て言いますか
餅 そんなもんなんですね
まあ楽しいでしょ それでも
喧嘩してそこ取ってやったこと
七五三のお宮参りは信仰が作った文化ですね
世界宗教は世界スケールの文化を作っています
例えばキリスト教は まあキリスト教は世界宗教ではないんだけど
あのキリスト教 あの軍人に乗っ取られたんだから
もう殺しまくっちゃって
キリスト教を広げちゃ広げたんだけど
で 殺しまくりながら人を愛しなさいというでしょ
で そうすると このキリスト教
イスラム教というのは戦争しながら人殺しながら続けて
例えばイスラム教はヨーロッパにも広がっちゃったでしょ
ヨーロッパ歴史でビザンティアなんとなんとかありますからね
で それでまたキリスト教でイスラムの人殺ったり
いろんなことで で 文化が広がるんですね
しかし 裏で宗教がなければそんな強くないんです
仏教も信仰する宗教だと勘違いされたので
仏教も複雑でややこしい文化を作ったんです
仏教はお釈迦様が涅槃にあられて
もう 100年  200年もっとかな
ね 経ったところで だいたい 300年
400になってくると
宗教にどんどん変わってきたんですね
大乗仏教は宗教になってから現れたものなんですね
で そうすると文化が必要なんです
宗教だから そこで仏教っていうのはかなり幅広い教えでしょう
しっかりした思考があるし
哲学もあるし いろいろあるんだから
文化そう単純じゃなくなっちゃうんです
微妙になる はい 次 文化の価値
みんな一緒に仲良く実行すること
ある程度で楽しい 例えば
あの成田山に行ってね
飢えている人みたいに豆拾うことは
客観で見ると恥ずかしいんだけど
でも結局楽しいんですね
あまりにも楽しいんだから
見学に行く外国人も豆拾うんです
拾ってから あれ これどうするの？ってわからない
それでもう厄介な日本人がこれは食べましょうとか
なんとか あなたの歳の数を食べてくださいと
この年になっちゃうと
ごめんね お腹のほうを壊しますから
だから私もじゃあ 10個ぐらい食べて
私は 10歳だよというような感じかな
単独行動したがる人間を一時的にでもまとめることができます
また 成田山を被害者にしましょう
で 成田山に行く人々はみんな単独行動でしょ
自分がお参りに勝手に行くんだからね
成田山の坊さんたちには何も言う権利ないんですね
しかし 成田山自体は文化でしょ
そちらに入っちゃうと
みんな結局はあの文化で言うとおりに
こちら入るなよとかね
左からずっと回ってこちらに行ってくださいと
言うとおりにやるんです
結局はそうなるんです
お正月 成田山に行ったら
この子供にこちらハンコまで押してくれるんです
で なんか成田山のね それでお守りだと
お風呂に入るまで それで洗っちゃいますからね
で ですから この文化っていうのは
単独行動する人間を一時的にでもまとめる
人は管理しやすい 文化があれば管理しやすい
日常の挨拶 軍人のしきたり
国家の祭りなど 会社の決まりなどで人間管理が進むんです
あの国も本当によくよく見ると
文化お祭りばっかりなんですよ
はい 日本の総理大臣は海軍を見学に行ったと言ったら
みんな並んでいろいろ変なことを
アホなことをやってお祭りやるんです
日本の国会もね 国会やってると
見てください お祭り結構ありますよ
しきたり 習慣 あれで管理しやすいんです
お寺の文化では人に落ち着いてもらうんです
そこでお寺も自分お寺文化を持ってるんです
日本のお寺では どんなお寺でも
その場合は日本に限ってないんだけど
お寺はあえて違う文化を持ってるんです
自分独特の だからその文化で
なんとなく人々は落ち着いて
気持ちよくなって 幸せな気分になって帰るようにとしているんです
時々狂暴な坊主たちも日本のお寺ではいるんだけどね
テーラワーダのお寺ではないんです
あまり坊主は出てこないんです
自由にやってくださいと
すごく文化の価値 続き
宗教世界の太鼓 すす 鐘
踊り 音楽 清めなどの無数のしきたりで
俗世間のことを一時的に忘れて
神秘世界を感じて欲しがるんです
麻薬みたいです 書いてあったっけ？書いてますね
あるでしょ？太鼓を叩くわね
特に南無妙法蓮華いう場合は
どんどん南無妙法蓮華経と何回叩くんですかね
それで木魚叩くまでトントントントン
ギャーギャーギャーとかね
私は腹そうではなくて
腹が立ってしょうがないんだけど
あれって全部もう文化ですね
それでどうな目的はなんか神秘世界体験させたいんですね
日常でね おにぎり食べて
お茶飲んでね それからサンドイッチも食っちゃって
そういう文化と違うもの
違う世界を味わって欲しがるんです
麻薬と似た効果を期待しています
ここで私が言いたいのは
お寺 教会で派手な祭りやって
例えば日本で今新興宗教あまりないんだけど
前に作られた新興宗教
今現役でやっているでしょ
ああいうところ すごい派手なんです
派手な仕来りあるんです
あれでなんとなく変な気持ちになるんですよ
考えてください 大太鼓をまあこちら八個
こちら八個 十六個並べて
体力のある男たちがあの棒でドンドンって叩きながら
南無妙法蓮華経と言っちゃうとどうなる？皆様の心が
変な雰囲気でしょ それで騙すんです
ブッダ見てください この宇宙の大日如来様が降りてきて
あなた方には祝福していたと
嘘でしょ？だから科学的に見てください
これ麻薬効果なんです
だから皆様やられますね
なんで私がやられるの？私はそういうところは丁寧に紹介してもらいよ
もらいますよ 紹介してもらって勉強もして
そいつらのお茶もお菓子も食べて悪口言って帰るんです
互いに仲良くするために
子供と若者も自分特有の文化を作ります
それ別なフェーズ 宗教は終わりました
そこで子供の文化を作りましょう
若者には若者文化 子供には子供の文化があるんです
なんで子供は何も知らないくせに文化を作るんですかね
仲良くするために 子供同士で
無知な人間が大した理由もなく作る習慣なので
文化には大した価値はないんです
結局は文化の価値は だから
仏教の我々の手を上げるところでも
こうやって手を上げても
こういう風に手を上げたってもどうってことないんです
私は言うのは これは儀式じゃないんだから
できれば意味を観察しなさいと
理性で そんなもんです
文化は 文明度の問題じゃないんです
それで守るべき文化があります
理性に基づいて作った習慣
例えば 窓口で皆列を作ってますでしょ
あれ文化です でも守るべき
壊すべき 守った方がいいでしょ
あれは理性に基づいているんです
注射する前に必ず アルコールの言っちゃうでしょ
あれ科学世界ですけど
文化が現れるんです 病院なんか見てくよ
結構文化あるでしょ 病院文化
それは仕方がないんです
それはアホじゃないんです
ある理由があって文化作ってるんです
工事中作業する人々は決まったパターンで安全対策を実行する
よくよく見ると そこまでやらなくてもいいんじゃない？ということもあるんだけど
例えば何も落ちるものはないんだけど
工事現場に行くとみんなヘルメット被るでしょ
まあ落ちるものあったらわかりますけどね
落ちるものまくっても
みんなヘルメット被ってるんですね
だから文化になってますね
でもそこは安全文化だから守った方がいいんです
はい これらに文化と言わないのは迷信ではなく
事実に基づいて作る習慣だからです
だから私は文化と言ったっても
皆様がそれに文化と言わないでしょ
銀行の郵便局の窓口で並んでいることは文化と言わないね
あるいは番号札を取って自分の番号を呼ぶまで待っている
文化と言わないね でも文化ですよ
あれは 皆様は文化と言わなくたっても
私は痛くも痒くもないんだけど
私は文化と言うんです
で 文化と皆様言わない理由が
あれが必要だからなんです
勝手なことをできないからなんです
で 皆様も夏 今お神輿の時代時期にもなってくるでしょ
あれは文化というんですね
皆様もお祭りというでしょ
だってあれは振るか振らないか
自分勝手に決めればいいんだからね
はい それで仏教と文化
客観 客観でなんかおかしいね
客観的で理性に基づいた文化
仏教は客観的で理性に基づいた文化を作るんです
あの仏教 もともと迷信じゃないんだからね
迷信じゃないんだけど
宗教にしたからといって
いくらか信仰入り込んでますけど
神々を信仰するとかね
入り込んでいるんだけど
仏教の理性の姿は壊せませんね
科学性は壊せません 誰に
ですから 仏教が作る文化がある程度でまとめなんです
結構意味があるんです
守った方がいいという文化を作るんです
それで我々は科学と仏教を比較してみましょう
科学は物質の構成を発見しようとします
生きるために必要な道具を開発します
科学者は 仏教は存在のからくりを発見したんです
したのです もう終わっているんです
存在輪廻を乗り越えて解脱に達する方法を発見しているんです
だから科学者はいろいろ携帯みたいなガラクタを作っている
仏教は存在のからくりを発見して
存在を乗り越えるためにガラクタを作ることできませんだから実践ということを教えているんです
結構似ているんです だから
科学信仰する人はいろんなパソコンやら携帯やらね
車やら道具に潰された人生を送るんです
仏教をやる人は 仏教も科学ですけど
生き方を変えて 客観的に観察しながら生きる生き方に変わっちゃうんです
道具はないんです 科学者は文化を作ることに興味は興味がないと同じく
仏教に文化を作る興味はないんです
興味はないんです 仏教は真理
生きることが苦であること
一切の現象は無常苦無我であることは事実で真理です
すべては因縁によって起きて
因縁が変わるとなくなります
これも真理 事実です 渇愛煩悩があるから
現象に 物事に 自分の命に価値があると思うこと
これが渇愛 これが煩悩です
価値があるんだと 例えばこのマイクロフォンに価値があるでしょ？あると思った途端
煩悩なんです 執着です
価値があるからでしょ？盗む気持ちになるのは
自分の財布が盗まれるかもね
なんで？価値があるからなんです
だから煩悩は執着を理解する
そういうことを理解できます
現象に価値がないんです
仏教いうのは 無知な愚か者が価値あると思っているだけ
ない 価値があると思うから
執着 煩悩が生まれて悪行為をする
そういうことで生命は輪廻転生します
煩悩があるから 渇愛があるから
要するに 煩悩渇愛わからない方々は価値があると思っているから
輪廻転生します だから人は解脱に達しているかないかということは
自己判断できますよ 自分がまともな道徳を守って
落ち着いて瞑想しながら
宗教っぽいみたい生活しているかも
だから俺が悟っていると私に聞いたって意味がない
本人が自分に世界のはこれこれいろんなものについて価値があるのかと
価値を感じるのかと思ったら悟ってないんです
この命すら生ゴミみたいだと
価値がないんだとわかっている人が悟っているんです
これ生ゴミや だからあのテーラワーダとかね
あの悟ったお坊さんたち歌っている歌の経典があるでしょ
読んでみてください 価値が一切ない
はい 人間の感情で無知で作る文化は関係ない
ですから 仏教 仏教には文化は関係ない
はっきり言います 子供たちが何か硬い紙で箱をなんか破って
硬い紙で紙をハサミで切って冠のように作って
それからピカピカ輝いているボール紙ありますね
金色のボール紙を貼って
ゴムバンドで後ろでつないで頭にかぶって
学校の何とかものがあったら
王の役をやるために行くんですね
あれ 冠の形なんですね
でも皆さん 誰でってそれを見たらね
あ 王冠だ すごいだと思う？思わない
ただよく頑張ったというだけでね
ですから 仏教は人間の文化はそういう風に見ているんです
幼稚園に行っている子供たち
あるいは小学校の子供たちが作った冠みたい
感じでね  悪くちゃいませんよ
あ 可愛い可愛い よくできたとかね
よくできてますよとかね
褒めたりはするんだけど
全然価値があるとは思ってないんです
そこは文化 ではなぜ仏教文化？解脱に達するための実践方法があります
実践が問題なく進んで成功するまで行うべき決まりがあるんです
たとえ話で言えば 安全運転するために守るべき決まりのようなもので
信仰ではありませんね
皆様は車を運転しながら
黄色い信号を見たら もう足がブレーキに行っているでしょ
赤くなった途端カチッと止まる
あれ 宗教？あれ信仰？じゃないんです
時々人が渡るために そちら緑になっちゃって
自分の信号は赤くなっている
人は渡ってないんです
誰もいない でも車を発進する
発進しません だから人がいないんだから飛ばせとはないでしょう
ある面で人がいなかったら進んでもいいんだけど
でもしない あれは文化です
しかし 大事な文化です
仏教の文化は瞑想を実践するために
これ成功するために 事故を起こさないために
しっかりと解脱するまで進むために作っている大事なものです
しきたり 文化 信仰のように見えるだけ
皆様には仏教もね 他の宗教と同じくしきたりいっぱいあるんだとかね
見えるかも 見えても構いませんよ
だって車を運転する人もそうやって信仰をやってますからね
仏教の国々では 理性的な文化と信仰型の文化が共存しています
あの 日本と違うんです
日本の仏教は あの 神秘的な文化だけで終わっているんです
あの禅寺はちょっと違います
禅寺の文化は凝り固まっているんだけど
ちゃんと修行に関わる文化しっかりあるんです
禅の文化が社会に漏れちゃったんです
みんな勝手に真似するんです
だから日本文化になっちゃった
茶道やらね 花道やらいろんな下らんって言ってアカンだからね
あの日本庭園とかね 私は仏教的な癖でね
何でも下らんでしょ まあ庭園とかそんなにくだらないではなくて
大変ですよ でもそこで禅寺が精神的な修行を期待しているんです
精神的に森羅万象 全部区別なく同じものやと体験しなさいと
それは社会に漏れちゃうと
まあ日本文化になるんです
だから禅寺以外はほとんどくだらない
迷信に凝り固まった文化以外何もないんです
そんな気にする必要はないんです
はい それでテーラワーダ
国々では 2種類の文化があるんです
一つは修行に関わる文化
もう一つは信仰に関わる文化
だって仏教は心理でありながら宗教でもあるんだから
なぜ仏教文化という続き
瞑想実践に関わる文化は
仏教国々では同じです
あの 例えば皆様がスリランカの瞑想道場に入っても
ミャンマーの瞑想道場に入っても
タイの瞑想道場に入っても同じです
すべてやり方はしきたりは決まりは全部同じです
あれは修行に関わるもので
すごい大事なんです 例えば日本で手術するでしょう
病院で手術するときはもうお祭りだけでしょ
簡単にやってくれないんですよ
まず血液が固めるためにどれぐらい時間かかるのかとチェックする
ここら辺 傷跡をつけて血をとってみて
じーっと待って 待っていて
看護婦さんがね はい この何秒かと言ってくる
それで薬には反応あるかないか調べる
大体 10回  15回ぐらい自分の名前を確かめる
はい あなたの名前を言ってくださいと
はい 年齢は？とかね うるさくてしょうがないんですよ
早くやりなさい カルテに書いてるでしょうと
それはダメなんです カルテに書いてる通りに手術するんだから
これ本人かと確かめなくちゃいけないんです
それは麻酔入れる前にも聞くんです
だから神社のお祭りと同じですよ
手術するときは祭りだらけで
でもそれはすべて大事でしょ
一つも手抜けてはいけないんです
命がかかっているんです
そういう風に仏教瞑想道場の決まりは守るしかないんです
アホな決まりは一つもないんです
タイ ミャンマー スリランカがそれぞれ仏教文化を作っています
これはタイ人に スリランカ人に
ミャンマー人に仏教は宗教ですよ
逆にだからタイ仏教 ミャンマー仏教あるんです
スリランカ仏教はあるんです
sex 供養と仏教は合体したので
その習慣の場合も差が見えます
例えばセックス供養っていうのは
どんな人間もやりたがるんです
だからタイでもあります
ミャンマーでもあります
スリランカでもあります
日本でもあります しかし
それぞれやり方が違います
スリランカは一番単純
セックス供養はすごいが単純で終わり
ミャンマーはそれよりちょびっと複雑
タイははちゃめちゃ複雑
タイの最近亡く死んだ王様がね
遺体は一年持ちますか？一年経ってから火葬するんです
かなり派手複雑 で 日本もそうでしょう
違う 同じじゃないんです
はい 次 文化の付き合い方
皆様はどうでもいいんだけど
私も疲れてきました あまり大した内容はないんだから
私にとっては疲れちゃいます
えっと 時間的に休暇取るかない
休憩取るかないか まああとほんの何枚しかないです
スライドは だから我慢しましょう
苦行しましょう どうやって分割付き合うのかと
平和 調和 秩序を守るために必要な習慣
他人の役に立つ習慣などを守りましょうよ
みんな仲良くしてくれるんだったら
まあ表面的にはアホらしいんだけど
構いませんよ ちゃんと守ってあげてください
はい は文化を守ることで人の役に立つならば
それはやった方がいいんです
例えば自分の国だったら
お釈迦様のウェーサーカ祭りなどなどになってくると
貧しい人々を助けるということをやるんですね
だから大量にいろんなものを持って行って配る
習慣になっています ご飯作って無理やり食べさせる
でもそれでも一年一回でも人を助かるんだからね
やった方がいいことになるんです
だから日本でもお盆でね
お盆であんなかっこ悪い踊りやるんじゃなくて
もっとなんかね 困っている人々を助けましょうとやった方がいいんじゃない？迷信
妄想 妄想 神話などで作られた文化は無関心である
批判する必要はない 無関心
だから 青鬼 赤鬼の場合は
あれは嘘だからね 別に別に無関心で構いません
理性 科学的な事実などで現れたしきたり
習慣などは これはしっかり守らなくちゃいけない
飛行機に乗る時の文化
それはしっかり守らなくちゃいけない
だって皆様は誰もテロリストはいないでしょう
だからといって あのセキュリティチェックの場合はね
文句言わないで従ってください
俺は日本人だからテロやるわけないでしょうにと言っても
言ったらね 飛行機に乗れません
だからちゃんと靴を外して
ベルトも外して ちゃんと出して
セキュリティチェックをやって
しっかりと それから飛行機に乗ったら
滑走路で飛行機はスピード出すでしょ
あれぐらい何のこともないんですよ
ベルト着けなくてもいいんですけど
ちゃんとベルト着けてください
なぜかというと 万が一飛行機が着陸できなかったならばブレーキかけるんですよ
その時は飛んでぶつかるんです
だって200キロ以上だからね
感じないだけで あの瞬間のスピードは
そういうことで 科学的にできてある文化はうるさくても守りましょう
仏教文化も 1 解脱に欠かせない習慣
2 調和を保つための習慣
2つあると理解しましょう
と ここで 1 はもう自由はないんです
2 はそれなりに 例えば
皆様はタイの仏教文化を輸入する必要はないんです
スリランカの仏教を輸入する必要はないんです
だから私は 普遍的な仏教しか喋ってないんです
真理しか喋ってないんです
スリランカの文化は皆様に押し付けてないんです
だから日本のテーラワーダ仏教をやっている方々は
日本人が仲良くお互い兄弟であると
仏教をやっている人はみんな同じ家族やと理解するために
いろいろ文化を考えて作ってください
私は別に邪魔しません
テーラワーダなりのお盆踊りとか
まあそれは気持ち悪いんだけどね
それから自由 文化と文明の自由
しきたり 習慣 文化などはなぜ大事？平和で幸せで生きるためです
ね はっきりしているでしょ
要するに生きていきたいという存在欲があるんです
生きていきたいという存在欲があるならば
文明を犯してはいけない
犯罪者になる文化を守りなさい
自由じゃありません 存在欲ある限り
存在欲があるから 習慣無視すること
しきたりを守らないことが怖いんです
だから皆様怖さ感じるでしょ？お盆でお墓参りしなかったらやばいな
これは とかね 戦争の怨念が来る
あれ 存在欲からなんです
お墓が夜飛んできて お前お参りしなかったでしょとかね
あの墓石しか自分の首に落ちません
でもどこかで怖いんです
あれは存在欲です 社会の批判
後ろめたさが怖いんでしょ？存在欲あるからです
結局 社会に操られているんです
存在欲ある人が 社会っていうのは人類のこと
人類に操られているんです
それで観察瞑想で生きることが苦であると発見して
生きることは一時的な現象に過ぎないのだと発見しして
一切のは空相であると発見して
煩悩が消えるようにする
すべて空相だったら煩悩ないでしょ？空相っていうのは価値がないということでしょ
例えば金と石って同じやとわかったら
金に特別価値がある ただの石ころと宝石って同じ石でしょうと思ったら
価値がある 煩悩がある
ない 存在欲を絶つんです
その人は聖者で 俗世間の文化習慣とは関係がありません
とは落ちてますけど まあそういうのは関係ない
だからお釈迦様やら阿羅漢たちは世間いうことには踊りません
離れているんです しかし
聖者だから この文化をもってブッダを批判することはできません
こちらは強いんです 脅すこともできません
存在欲ないんだから お釈迦様は批判されたのは一か所というかね
一つだけですね お釈迦様は人が来ても立ちません
すごい年寄りの有名人が来ても
立ってインド人みたい挨拶はしません
インドではスリランカで同じですけど
年上の人が来るとすぐ立つんです
我々もよくやります 立って年下の人はちゃんと挨拶する
これは皆様 インドやスリランカ
テレビ番組だって同じことなんです
年の人にすぐ挨拶する
すぐ礼をする テレビ番組だからとか
変なことをしません で
それだからね お釈迦様がすごいお年寄りのバラモン人が来ても
座ったままでいて もう一応言葉だけでは挨拶をする
言葉だけでよく来てくれましたとかね
遠いところからとか そういう言語
お元気でしょうか？とかね
それは聞きます うん 早くやめなさいと言ってます
バッテリーの寿命が はい
そういうことで ブッダが
あの年寄りが来たら立ちませんと挨拶しないという批判は受けたことがあります
そこで仏様が言うのは
これ年齢じゃないんだよと
心を完全に清らかにしている
している解脱者こそが老人だと
年上だと だからそれだけはできませんと
なぜかというと お釈迦様は傲慢ではなくて
お釈迦様が立ったら この自然法則で相手が壊れちゃうんです
だから人々のことを心配して
やらないんです お釈迦様に頭を下げるべきなんです
それだけなんですね 他
別に誰も 文化には束縛されてない
解脱者は文化に束縛されません
ですから 皆様が文化から
文明から しきたり 習慣から
迷信から あれやこれやくだらんものはもういっぱいありますけど
この世の中で 自分の独立して生き方は何ですか？操られているのはどこですかとわけもわからないぐらいでしょ
よくよく見るとほとんど操られているだけなんですね
そこから自由になりたければ
存在欲を生きていきたいというあの欲望を足してください
それで自由になります
はい それで終了だと なんかこれ閉じる
どうやって閉じるんですかね
これパソコン あ  OK はい
それで終了になりました
今日の話のポイントをまとめると
この文明文化っていうのは普通の人間作るものだからね
そんな完璧ではないし
毎日変わるしね そんなのに引っかかる必要はないし
皆様にも文明に何か貢献すること
文化に何かを貢献して加えることはできるんです
だから文明はしょうがない
これはもう海の中に生きている魚はみんな海の水の中にいなくちゃいけない
しかし 各魚が自分に適した環境で生きている
そんな感じ だから海の海水は文明で
それぞれ魚グループが自分の住みか別に作っているんですね
それが文化で ということで考えて
それから私は今日大事な仏教のポイントはすべて因果法則で
しかし 人間というのは宇宙的な因果法則の中の一部
海の一部ですけど 我々は自分に適した小さな因果法則のループ法則って毎日生活しているんですね
はい 以上です じゃあ質問とか
それでは質疑応答の時間 40
分ぐらい取りたいと思うんですけど
皆さん何か今日のことに関連するえー
構成とかについて ちょっと手挙げてみて
まあとりあえず迷った方が言うまでに行きたい
存在欲を少しでも減らしていく方法というのを改めて教えていただきたいんですけれども
存在欲は少し減らす うーん
まあ難しいんですね 半分死んでもいいやというそういう生き方ね
あの執着を減らす ものは変化するんだから
まあ何が起きても因果法則なんです
そういう風に考えると
存在欲は減ります 具体的に言います
自分の子供が家にあったすごい大事なものを壊しちゃった
結構高価なもので 困りますね
自分はこんな高価なものを壊しちゃって
あるいはもしかするとこれは親の形見かもしれませんしね
日本でもこの 1個しかなかったかもしれませんしね
それで自分の子供だからもう弁償しろと言ったって
どうしますかね そこで精神的に悩むでしょ
あれ 執着なんです その瞬間であのね
世の中のものは何でも壊れますよと
だからちゃんと原因が揃って壊れ
壊れました それだけでしょうと思って落ち着く
だから例えば 1,000万の価値ある壺かもしれません
子供がどこどこちょこちょこやっちゃったところで
ボキャンと落ちちゃったと
その時も まあいいや まあ別にという感じでいられれば
それ訓練できますよ だって朝から晩までキャーキャーとね
子供に怒鳴ったり 旦那に怒鳴ったりやってるでしょ
あれ 執着なんですね で
そういうところで訓練するんです
もう何か悩んだりすることっていうのは
ほとんどすべて執着  執着
執着 うん 例えば自分ががんになって
ああ そうか 細胞だから当たり前と思ってほしい
ああ がんですか？なんとか
まあ執着でしょ だって自分に変なことを起きてがんになったわけじゃないでしょ
因果法則の流れでなっただけ
ああ そうか で それから落ち着いて
ああ できることならやる
治療できるならばやる
治療できないと思ったら
ああ そうか で それ そういう風に毎日悩むことあったら執着
何かに悩んだら執着 そうやってチェックしてください
楽しくなりますよ すごい幸せになります
大体執着のない人は過去に悩まない
例えば 車を運転して事故っちゃった
それで あ ま 気をつけなかったらよかったのにとかね
前の人が急ブレーキするということは知らなかったんだからって
そこは過去でしょ あ 事故っちゃった
次どうする？それだけ
あ 怪我人がいる 大丈夫？逆に向こうの車のせいで事故を起こしたかもしれません
あんた方大丈夫？とかね
次にやることするんです
じゃあ連絡しましょうとかね
すごいかっこいいですよ
生き方は それで我々執着あるんだから
なんでこんなこと起こっちゃったんですかとかね
過去に引っかかってアホなことをするんです
だからはっきり言えば悩むのはアホなんです
だから私みたいな何であろうとも何でもバカにしてるでしょ
で そこはまあちょっと態度が悪いかもしれませんだけど
でも楽しく生活しているんです
はい 性の訓練考えてください
もう一つなんですけど
起こってしまったことなので
起こらないこれから先のことを悩んでいるっていうのは
どのように  先が悩んでるんだったら
これ執着ですよ だって知らない先でしょ
それはあなた 産んでもない子供に対して
子供の病気について悩んでるような感じで
まだ産んでないんだから
くだらないんですよ あれ
長さんにすべさがついたらどうする？とかね
もし日本が 野生のクマさんたちには翼がついてあちらこちら飛んできたら大変でしょう
これって悩むバカがいる？起きてないことに
大体癖だからね 私は因果法則でパターンというものを教えたでしょう
そこは悩みパターン作ってるんですね
だからこれ因果法則なんです
将来の出来事を妄想する
それは管理できないんだだから悩む
それで将来のことを悩む人はネガティブことを妄想するんです
逆もできます 明日私には宝くじ一等賞当たるはずとかね
当たったらどうしようと当たらないんだから
それからガクンと泣いちゃいますけどね
将来のこと いくらでも
だからそういうパターンなんですよ
だからネガティブな妄想をする人は
いつでもネガティブ妄想して悩む
ネガティブ妄想して悩む
しかし そこでしっかりした因果のサイクルが起きちゃったんです
妄想は存在しないかもしれませんだけど
現実に悩みがあるんですね
それは悪業になるんです
だから自分が悪業溜まって溜まっていくんです
悩むために悪業溜まるんです
それで物の見事に将来は不幸になります
問題ありません 心配することはありません
過去のことで悩む人には
将来はもう必ず精神病気で終わります
将来のことを思って悩む人は
との通りにそれよりひどく不幸にはなります
それは因果法則です そういうことで
将来のことを妄想するのも執着です
どうでもいいやと 明日はと
今日でしょうね 日常はという風にやらなくちゃいけないんです
はい  ありがとうございます
次は  本日はありがとうございました
日本文化ではお盆というものがありますね
心理の観点からすると
亡くなった人と話したり会ったりということが本当にできるんでしょうか
父が亡くなって いろいろまだまだしたいことがあったので
ちょっとついちゃいますのです
よろしくお願いします
ちょっと聞き取れないところがありました
日本文化にお盆という習慣がありますけど
お盆では先祖の霊が戻ってくるという
そういう言い伝えですけど
仏教的にはそういう亡くなった方と話をしたりとか
また会えたりとか そういうことはできるんでしょうか
絶対できませんね これは自己暗示に過ぎないんです
面白い そんな文化は 例えば亡くなった先祖たちが今生まれている世界で
一年に例えば千日かかるとしましょう
そうすると一年一回 自分の孫たちがね
くだらんことをやっているんだから
あいつらの様子を見なくちゃあかんって言ったら
合わないでしょ 時間が
地球の時間と だからこの人間が勝手に作る文化でしょう
しかし 先祖を大事に思うことは別に
人間としては文明人でしょ
犬猫には葬式ないでしょ
犬が自分の母親が死んだからといって知らない母親であることもね
我々は人間だから 文明人だから
そこら辺は線香を焼したりはする
まあそれだけですね で
まあ気楽にやってください
別に もし誰かが亡くなった人と喋ったという実際データがあったら私に教えてください
テレビで誰かさんが出たんだけど
あの人は完全インチキ野郎だからね
よし では次  ヴィパッサナー瞑想を始めたんですが
1ヶ月ぐらい経ったから
瞑想をやってない時に雑念がバーッと湧き上がってきて
たくさん湧き上がってきて
これは何かやり方が違うんじゃないかなと思ってるんですけど
やり方が間違ってるんじゃないかと思うんですけど
その 1ヶ月ぐらい経ったら雑念が絶えて
瞑想をやってなくて 普段に湧き上がってくるっていうのはどんなやり方を間違えた考えになるんでしょうか
まだ聞き取れてないんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想を始めて 1ヶ月ぐらい経つのですが
瞑想をしていない時ですね
していない時に 以前にも増して激しく雑念
妄想が 湧いてくることがあるそうです
これは瞑想のやり方が何か間違っているせいではないかというふうに推測されているのですが
いかがでしょうか  何でも妄想で処理しないでください
それだけは現実として見てください
瞑想をやっていない子は
ものすごい勢いで妄想が入ってくると
それだけ だから 瞑想 何ですか？間違っているではなくてね
まあ間違っているという間違っている人間というのは期待感があるんだからね
これは簡単になくなりませんよ
瞑想しながら何か期待する
そこでご自分が雑念 妄想なくなるだろうと期待したでしょうね
物事は自分の好みで起きませんよ
それは知恵なんです 例えば
この照明の明るさはあなたの好みで起きているんですか？ないでしょう
そちらのそちらの法則があります
だからまあ 例えば この今
空気をコントロールしているでしょ
こちらの空気がいくらかコンディションをコントロールしていることは
私がそう期待したからではないんです
で これはそれ機械の法則によってそうなっているだけ
だからすべてそういうことで因果法則なんですね
はい 俺が妄想をやめたいなと思ったっても
そうやめられるものじゃないんです
こちらシステムがあるんです
システムを理解しない限りはね
例えば この舞台で今たくさん照明があるでしょ？照明消えてください
消えてくださいとだいたい 8回ぐらいお願いしてみて
消えるかないか 100回いた 1万回
1億回言ったっても消えません
これの因果法則があるんです
それだったらパシッと消すことはできます
だから妄想が現れる因果法則がありますよ
それは発見したら大丈夫ですよ
はい だから今言った答えは
この自分の瞑想は別に問題ないんです
全然問題ないんだけど
まだまだ期待というちょっとした
ゴミがあるんです  ヴィパッサナー瞑想をすれば
妄想とか雑念が普段出てきたりするのだと期待してたんだけど
それは違いますか？ システム発見してくださいよ
科学的に見てください
因果法則でシステムできている
それを発見して自分でいじればいいんです
例えば舞台が暗いんだったらわかりますね
照明のなんとかあのなんとかイルミネーション足らない
もう 1個つけます それだけ
だからシステムわかれば
あのヴィパッサナー瞑想をどんどんやっていると
どうしたっても あの恐ろしい思考妄想はどんどん減っていきますよ
当然 しかし そちら神秘はないんです
神秘はないんです 科学なんです
瞑想をやったり 実況中継やると
自分の心と脳みそが現実知る能力を上げるんです
現実知る能力が上がると
妄想することを減らさなくちゃいけないんです
だって 瞬間の時間でできる仕事は一個だけだからね
そういう法則で自然に妄想の量が減るんです
瞑想をやめたら まあ妄想だけになっちゃうんです
だからあなたは普通も確認しながら生活する能力が必要なんです
仕事をする時でも 何かやっている時でも
ご飯を食べている時でも
観察する能力 それができてくると
妄想する必要はなくなっちゃうんです
うん じゃあ頑張ってください
そういう風に  今日 父のお話ありがとうございます
お話の冒頭にエコーについて
あの少々マイクロフォンを離してください
はいはい  お話の冒頭にですね
エコーについて触れられたかと思うのですが
私も日々の瞑想の功徳を親しい人ですとか
亡くなった方にエコーをしたいと思っているんですけれども
それは瞑想の後に 例えばエコの文を唱えるとか
そういうやり方でよろしいでしょうか？ はいはい
それは結構です うん 全然大丈夫です
いつでもエコーしてください
私たちもね もうやってますよ
毎日 毎日エコーしています
はい  そのエコーの文とタイミングというのは
やっぱり瞑想の後っていうのがよろしいでしょうか
やっぱり何もいいことをしていないと
何をエコーするんですかね
だからそれっていうのは常識でしょ
うん  ありがとうございます
はい 後ろ  はい すみません
ヴィパッサナー瞑想を日頃やっているんですけれども
瞑想する時に言葉を使ってしなさいというふうに長老から言われているんですけども
こうやってずっと経験していくうちに
言葉を使わないでこの実況中継ということができるんでしょうか
はい あの集中力はものすごくシャープになるとできます
あの言語のレベルを超えなくちゃあかんです
それは必ずいつでも気づきっていうのは行っていないと
でも あの言語なしできる時間も短いんですよ
ある時間できてまた元に戻るんですね
だから あの それはそういうものなんです
あの最終的にすごい集中力が上がって
ヴィパッサナーの観察はしっかりと動くと
あの言葉はめる入れる時間ないんです
だからそのままささささっと観察はできる
でもその時間それほど長くないんです
すぐ普通に戻るんです
だからもうどんな例えは思い浮かばないんですね
例えば自分が体の筋力使って何かやろうと使うでしょ
できますけど すぐ疲れるでしょ
1 日中はできません 例えば
自分では運べないぐらい
何か何か 例えば車が倒れちゃったと
これ元に戻さなくちゃいけない
これは機械でやるでしょ
普通は でも何か人が中に入っていて
人を出さなくちゃいけない
ああ これ大変 人の命やって
これであなたはものすごい力入れて車をガクンと元に戻しちゃう可能性ありますね
俺には何といいますか
スーパーマンみたいな力あるぞ
どこでもやる それはできませんね
一回だけ そうやってこの力絞るということには
ライフライフスパンが短いんです
人は歩くならば 10キロも歩ける
勢いで走るならば 1 キロで終わりでしょ
はい はい 次の方 長老は大乗仏教についても日本文化としてご理解が深いということで
一つ質問をさせていただきたいんですが
あの禅宗というものがございまして
こちらに伺う前は 私は鎌倉の円覚寺という禅宗のところで
座禅の初心者っていうところに参加しておりました
そういうあの座禅のお坊さんも非常に真面目に修行してらっしゃるんですけれども
あの座禅の修行のみで解脱するということは
長老 長老のお考えとしては難しいというふうにお考えでしょうか？あともう一つ
それはただ文化比較ということで
質問する意味もないことかもしれないですね
今質問させていただきたいのは
その禅宗のお坊様に解脱を目標としていらっしゃるんですよねって聞いたことがあったんですが
解脱は目標としていませんっていうはっきりとお答えになったんですね
それは私のような素人が考えることじゃないよという意義なのかもしれませんし
そこら辺は詳しくはわからないんですが
例えばテーラワーダのお坊様に解脱を修行の目的としていらっしゃるのですか？と聞いたら
皆様は解脱を目標としていらっしゃいますというふうに
素人にもお答えになるのでしょうか
（笑）今スリランカで最近若い若き私から見れば若いなんで人々
お坊さんたちが説法しているんです
3時間半  3時間の説法
私はこのスライドを作りながら
ずっとそのお坊さんの説法を聞いていたんです
だからスライドはいい加減で
説法にはすごい興味いくんですね
だから 2つ聞いたんだから
6時間  7時間なんです
そのお坊さんが説法始まる前に
皆様誓願してください
この説法終わると必ず預流果に達しますと
それで預流果に達している方々は
上の上の悟りに達しますと
しっかりと誓願意起を起こして
これから説法を聞いてくださいと
だから瞑想のところじゃないんだよ
説法を聞いても解脱に達しなさいと
だから説法ももう並みじゃないんですよ
素晴らしい だから何のことなく 7時間も聞いているんだから
私も だから私はもっと年上の経験のある坊主ですけど
でも真理は真理だからね
そういうわけで テーラワーダの場合は早く悟れよ
このバカという態度なんです
お前何回地獄に落ちたいのかと
無始なる過去から自己の地獄の苦しみを打ち感じて
こんなくだらない生活して
子供の奴隷で 旦那の奴隷で
社会の奴隷でくたくたに生きてきて
どこまでやるつもりですかと
だからそれは厳しく言うんです
日本の場合は まあ私の世界と違いますから
何とも言えませんね でも座禅は解脱を目的にするべきっていうのは当たり前です
偉い方のお坊様が根本的にそこら辺は素人に見えるにしても
間違った言い方をしていらっしゃる
知らない 私はもう  そこら辺はそう言われると思いました
だから私も言いますから
解脱解脱とか こんなくだらんことを置いておいてね
だから解脱解脱素人が思っちゃうと煩悩でしょ？だから私も解脱しなさいと言わないで
煩悩 執着をなくせ 執着をなくせと
それだけ言ってます だからスリランカの場合は仏教の文化だから
一応文化的に解脱に達しなさい
預流果に悟りなさいと言う
そこで次に言うのは なんであんた方まだ馬鹿で預流果に達しないのかと
いで その説明行くんです
すると執着の説法に行くんです
執着を説法して もう聞いてる人々をくったくった馬鹿にするんです
それで恥ずかしくなっちゃって
なんてやっぱり真理はこういう真理だなとわかって心が変わるんです
だから向こうは長い伝統でね
慣れてますからね まあ日本のことは私はよくわかりませんね
文化のことだったら理解できますけどね
まあ執着的な解脱ではなくて
輪廻を乗り越えたい 苦しみをなくしたい
もうどこまでやるのかと
この苦しみはね と自分で考えた方がいいんじゃない？うん
では ありがとうございました
自己を観察するようになるだけでも
私はすごいとすごく助かるというふうに思います
その次のステップとしてですね
自分の欲 執着そういうものが見えた時に
現在の世の中の中で実際の生活をしていくとなると
やはり資本主義の生活
生産性とか生産をしていくところには
やはり欲が必要であり
欲に根差した社会の構造というのがあって
そこで生きていかなければならないという現実があると思います
一方で 先生のおっしゃるようなことを突き詰めていくと
やはり最終的には出家ないとかしないといけないような印象を私は受けています
私の質問は その間の道があるのでしょうか？つまり
実際的な社会の中で実際的に生きていく
それで欲を認めて立つ欲を満足させるような生き方で
仏教的な幸せというのは
その延長上に先生はあるというふうに思いますか？それともむしろ最終的には
はい もう十分 えーとですね
この中道があるんです
中道が慈しみで実践するんです
例えば会社で欲がなければできませんでは嘘でしょう
欲がなくてもできるでしょ
例えば子供にご飯をすくって食べさせる
あ 我が子は可愛い可愛いという感情なくても食べさせるでしょ
子供の健康にいいもの
で 子供が食べたがらないんだけど
食べなくちゃいけないものとか
客観的に食べさせるでしょうに
自分の子供がすごく怪我した
それでショックを受けちゃって
感情でね 欲で ああ なんてことですか
これではなくて 怪我したら病院に連れて行って治療させてあげることできるでしょ
あ 君が怪我しちゃったね
じゃあ早く手当てしないと感染しますよ
じゃあ病院に行きましょうと
できるでしょ どちらが上司にあるんですか？例えば子供が病気
怪我しちゃって お母さんがギャーギャー泣いたり興奮しちゃったりしてね
正しい手当する？その女が
かえって危険でしょ 客観で
あ こいつは怪我しちゃった
だからいじらないで 丁寧にこうやって運んで
じゃあ病院に連れて行こう
そうすると冷静でお医者さんにこんな風な感じでこういうことを決まったよと
それでお医者さんもすごいしっかりと説明くれたんだから
調べてしっかりと手当をする
医者が調べると 先生 私の子供を助けてください
早くやってください 言っちゃうと先生も腹が立つでしょ
だから貪瞋痴で皆様方は失敗から失敗しているんです
この世の中は欲でやったからといってろくな結果ないでしょうに
慈しみでやってみてください
商売は慈しみでやる 会社は慈しみで人を助ける目的でやる
品物開発は人間を楽にしてあげたいと
やってみてくださいよ
ものの見事にうまくいくんです
だから仏道が道なんですよ
アホがいるんだけど アホに合わせる必要ないんです
例えば 我々 我々がいる村
住んでいる地方で犯罪者がいる
ヤクザもいる まとめな立派な人間もいる
だからあなたはヤクザに合わせる
犯罪者にも合わせる 合わせる必要ないんです
できれば排除するんです
だから世の中 貪瞋痴で世界戦争を引き起こしているからといって
なんで私たちはその猿真似する必要あるんですかね
常識で見れば タダではご飯くれないし
業は業のからくりですからね
業は仕事をして収入を得るようになっているんです
だから仕事をする 仕事とは人が助かることでしょうに
それには貪瞋痴は要りません
欲は要りません これ邪魔なんです
だから細菌は個に個でも感染して欲しくない
細菌は 1万個に感染したら病気になりますよと
じゃあ 100個ぐらいいいんじゃない？とか
いらん  100個でも だから貪瞋痴を控えて
だから皆様に貪瞋痴あるんだから
慈しみをバッファーに使ってください
悟ったら要らない 慈しみのバッファーは
だから皆様にヴィパッサナー瞑想より先に
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと言っているんです
それは貪瞋痴がなく 幸福に生きる秘訣なんです
これはバッファーなんです
だから会社で私を褒めてほしいとかね
もう上司に私を高く評価してほしいとやんな
貪瞋痴を置いておいて
自分が真面目に真剣に仕事をした方が生命の役に立つ
会社の役に立つ それは延長的で
社会の役にも立つ それで十分
私は慈悲をやってやる
という気持ちでやってみてください
それは中道です 一部評価する
評価する必要はないんです
例えば あなたも真面目に瞑想して
その時は貪瞋痴がなく
会社に行ったら貪瞋痴にどっしり
と そうすると成長しないでしょう
洗っても汚す 洗っても汚すだったら
いつだってもきれいにならんでしょ
だからヴィパッサナーを始めた人々は
ほほ 前と違って倍仕事してください
会社 頼んだ色よりもやってあげてください
ちょっと三十分待ってくれますか？大丈夫
一時間で待ってあげれますよと
そういうふうにやって
しかし 貪瞋痴を使わないでください
なぜならば あなたの仕事で生命は助かっている
それだけ そういうことで
解脱に達するまで 自分の鎧は厳しめです
頑張ってください  はい
まだ若いかもしれませんけど
ちょうど時間になりましたので
これで終了したいと思います
はい では最後の誓願 はい
誓願 進めてください はい
御一緒に唱えましょう
ドゥッカパッターチェニン
ドゥッカバヤッパッターチェニン
バヤー ソーカッパッターチェネッソーカー
ホントゥサンディティターニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい ありがとうございます
これで終了いたします
ありがとうございます
カンティパラマンタポーティティンカーニッバーナンパラマンワダンティブッダ